on s'est demandé quels sont les effets
du défi 28 jours sans alcool sur la
santé les médecins britanniques 15 mois
c'est pose exactement la même question
elle a mesuré l'impact de quatre
semaines d'abstinence sur 102 gros
buveurs des hommes des femmes qui vivent
en moyenne 4 à 5 20 par jour donc
beaucoup
après quatre semaines sans alcool
doctement à noter chez ces patients une
réduction de 15 à 20% de graisse
hépatique c'est le genre de gras qui
peut causer une cirrhose du foie
en plus il note une baisse de 28% de la
résistance à l'insuline bref après à
peine un mois le pancréas des cobayes
gérait plus facilement au sucre ce qui
diminue leur risque de diabète en
publiant ces données le dr maure a dit
que s'il pouvait inventer un médicament
qui avait les mêmes effets il serait
tout simplement milliardaire ajoutons qu
arrêter de boire tout si bon pour le
portefeuille
si les cobayes de l'étude ne buvait que
du vin à 15 alors la bouteille 28 jours
d'abstinence signifie pour eux 280 $ de
plus dans leurs poches
en plus si on ne boit pas et bien on a
plus de chance de perdre du poids
mais respectez un mois d'abstinence ça
ne donne pas la permission de consommer
abusivement d'alcool tout reste d'année
non seulement on reprend le poids perdu
les économies s'envolent mais les
problèmes de foie vont inévitablement
recommencé à se développer en fait
l'importance de l'étude britannique
s'est pourtant démontré les bienfaits
d'un mois sans alcool elle montre
beaucoup plus l'impact d'une
consommation excessive sur la santé
oui c'est bien de ne pas boire pendant
un moment mais c'est encore mieux de
boire avec modération et de s'abstenir
au moins deux jours par semaine et
encore aujourd'hui à un canadien sur
cinq qui boit de façon excessive et au
canada les problèmes d'alcool sont à
l'origine d'un plus grand nombre
d'hospitalisations que les crises
cardiaques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]